ian bagg is known as a crowd work master
but he doesn't do crowd work what's a
clearing firm because a kid that you
guys hired for no money has no clue what
you do
ian's secret sauce to crowd work is to
have a conversation with the audience
and like all great conversations
requires great listening
what's that stock stock stocks stock
stocks stocks
your boss has tourette
see he did a punch line and now he's
tagging it up by basically just
repeating the same joke over and over
again
shot shot shot shot shots
takes learning conversation it takes
being helped to listen to somebody to
give an answer to so for the comics out
there doing crowd work
listen closely to the audience member
responding to you and look for these
little moments that you can then blow up
into big laughs so you can do killer
crowd work just like